what did they think was going to happen
let's just let's just surmise for a
second
that we were that we were going to uh
pretend
like they always do we're going to
pretend
like they were successful and they would
have overturned the election
what did they think donald trump was
going to do with the constitution after
that
did they think he was just going to love
the document and think oh this
thing's fantastic all i did was have to
overturn it and bam on the president
still
did we really think that after his
second term he would
peacefully transfer power after we let
him
after we let him try and and maybe
successfully succeed
to commit a coup is that what is that
what these people thought
about what this podcast is gonna be
we're gonna talk about political issues
social issues
and we're gonna do it in a progressive
type of way and a
[ __ ] you type of way as you guys know my
favorite phrase is
[ __ ] um and it's kind of a protest term
so it's a protest to all those who you
want to protest
it's an easy way a very easy way
to protest an idea a group of people a
certain person
and to show your protest loud and proud
[ __ ] em
so you're probably gonna hear the word
[ __ ] you're gonna hear a lot of curse
words
uh but we're gonna talk about a lot of
different issues and we're probably
going to
really commentate on a lot of different
peep everyone loves it i say that
[ __ ] um everyone loves that
that's something i've said for a long
time i actually it's that's a shortened
version that you guys get on tiktok
because tic toc is only 60 seconds long
so
i can't say the full version of [ __ ]
but since it's the very
first episode of the podcast and i got
plenty of time i got all the time that i
want
i might as well give you the elongated
version it's [ __ ] in the ass
[ __ ] em so that's and you can also do
the whole uh
[ __ ] trump and anyone who looks like
trump
[ __ ] um and then you can add anyone's
name into that little phrase
anybody and one in particular today that
i'd like to give a shout out to
is [ __ ] louie gohmert and anyone who
looks like
louie gohmert [ __ ] up folks are
and by folks i mean uh fascist nazi
republicans
are standing on the floor uh
basically basically saying
that oh joe biden's going to be
inaugurated in seven days
why are we even here what could possibly
be the purpose of us
impeaching the president if in seven
days he's gone
well it's nice for you to admit it now
that there is
there was a violent insurrection on the
capitol
where the [ __ ] were you sons of [ __ ]
on december 14th
i remember moscow mitch mcconnell coming
to the senate floor
and getting getting excoriated for it
for coming out and saying it's over
it's done joe biden won [ __ ]
you ain't got a shot that thing on the
sixth that's gonna happen
that thing's ceremonial and from that
point on the president united states
encourage these people to go to
washington encourage
these people to fight
and that's why we're at the moment that
we're at an impeachment and that's why
right now
as we speak right here they are voting
on the floor of the house to impeach
donald trump
for the second time for inciting
insurrection which
is is a easy way of saying treason